warning this video contains strong
language and scenes of extreme violence
which is awesome hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to let's play
Punk's not dead the premiere
face-punching simulator okay so as you
can see the graphics are absolutely
unparalleled with anything I've ever
seen in my entire life um the writing is
absolutely incredible in the story
behind this it's just just absolutely
tremendous I can't even I can't even
begin to wrap my head around the kind of
character development has to go into
games like this I mean it's just
absolutely astonishing in the the level
of sophistication that gaming has come
to today anyway you're this little guy
and you got to teach people that punk is
not dead
through sharing and kindness as you just
generally share your fists with their
face and these guys they'll come around
they'll try to shoot you or whatever the
little green guys will pull out a gun
and just try to shoot you for some
stupid reason because they believe that
punk is dead and you have to prove to
him not you son of a [ __ ] get back here
I will freakin murder your face alright
it's a very important when you're
playing this game to not get too
emotionally involved because that's how
Punk got dropped down in the beginning
I'm guessing those are spouts of blood
or fire hydrants I'm gonna assume that
they're blood fire hydrants and that
they're shooting Oh big guy now oh you
want a piece of this yeah I didn't think
so
so anyway let you travel through the
world you begin to contemplate your
place in here and you begin to try to
understand what what you're the true
meaning of life is as you contemplate
how Punk affects the world and as you
pounce people in the face I'm gonna
punch that [ __ ] I know which one you
would get back here I know it's funny
was you think I didn't see ah they shot
me the sons of [ __ ] they shot me how
dare they oh man how many lessons do I
gotta teach these guys this is
absolutely ridiculous
you can hide behind cars to dodge the
bullets or you can just jump over them
like a badass
ah ja madam well how fair was that this
is absolutely ridiculous these sons of
[ __ ] need to just stand still and
take their lesson to the face you
proceeded a punch I don't know if I
mention that and you punch them in the
face and you rocket them across the
screen to try to get as many people as
you can but the same time they will run
away the little freaking bastards oh I'm
trying to control my language this is a
very kid-friendly game oh god damn it
your mother humper son of a [ __ ] monkey
okay anyway anyway besides all of that
it's just uh that's just a name we call
each other because we're all friends
here
we're just you know this is like any
mosh pit this is what I do out in the
middle of the street you know I went a
mile I'd like to think its life as my
mosh pit you know I don't like to be
limited by boundaries as you know normal
outdoors and civil society and laws you
know everything is meant to be punched
in the face even lampstand and people
and babies and children basically
anything's fair game when it comes to
punching in the face so just go out be
free do all the face punching you want
and have fun with it you know that's
what life is all about just having fun
get out of the freaking way you stupid
green bastards I see you hiding in that
corner over there you don't think I'll
punch you in the face tow clocked you
out of here Green [ __ ] call you brah
also I want to mention again the
sophistication of the riding in this
game is just absolutely stellar I can't
I can't believe that you know this
wasn't awarded more awards for its
incredible storytelling in the precision
in the gameplay mechanics I mean it
really feels as though I'm living in a
struggle world that doesn't believe in
punk and what it is that was a nice
combo there by the way I hope you all
noticed that I am a professional face
puncher in real life you know mostly
it's just uh people who don't follow my
exercise program of extreme squatting yo
de don't understand that I'm gonna
frickin punch you in the face if you
don't do
the track god dammit okay so anyway
that's pretty much the face-punching
experience you can expect more levels
extreme gameplay and super awesome
graphics so that is get Punk's not dead
the face-punching simulator so hope you
all enjoyed it
this was an exciting and interesting
adventure into the sophistication of the
world today so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that i've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
pull that out there right now